i'm not against vaccines okay
i'm not even necessarily against the
covet vaccine
however the neurotic creeps
that keep demanding that we all get this
vaccine no matter our risk level
no matter how young or healthy we are
who just insist on it who want to watch
us do it
they are making me significantly less
inclined
to get the vaccine case in point
brian stelter cnn who has this
voyeuristic creepy desire to watch
conservatives on television
getting jabbed with the kovid shot
it's really important to see all these
tv anchors personalities
showing themselves getting the shot
we've seen a lot of vaccine selfies
from lots of folks at lots of different
networks uh it's been really inspiring
to see
you know the today show even brought the
the co-host outside
for a live group vaccination this week
and rachel maddow on friday on msnbc
talked about how
she was really fearful of the needle
really worried about it
and yet it was important to get the shot
and she did and there she is talking
about it on air
so i say all of that to make the
following point
where are tucker and sean hannity and
laura ingram where is ainsley earhardt
and steve ducey and brian kilmeade
where are the biggest stars on fox
getting vaccinated
i get it's a personal choice i get
that's between you know
the hosts and their healthcare provider
but everybody else is doing it right
matt i mean all across television all
these anchors
are rolling up their sleeves why do you
think we haven't seen the biggest stars
on fox news
get vaccinated or show us their vaccine
selfies
it's really important that they show us
their vaccine selfies it's so
there's nothing more important to public
health than for some young and healthy
conservative tv hosts to get a shot on
tv
right i love he says it's really
inspiring to watch these people who have
done it and he shows a picture of
himself
it's so inspiring it's so virtuous
because of course
this is not about prudential judgments
and risk assessment
this is about a new scientific
sacrament in the religion of secular
progressivism i'm michael noel's
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show really
really crazy stuff i spoke at ave maria
college
on friday was it thursday or friday it
was my first
speech back on campuses in 14 months
i had done it i was supposed to do about
20 campus speeches last year
they all got canceled except for one or
two just before coronavirus then
starting in march they all got canceled
obviously because the colleges were
closed
it was great to be back and
coincidentally we spoke
uh about this religion of secular
progressivism the same kind of craziness
that brian stelter is implying and
uh i i recommend you go check out the
talk i really enjoyed it
who knows how much longer it'll stay
online because it questions not the
science
i'm using a lot of air quotes today but
i i really am only using the air quotes
around the word science
it's this way of justifying
all this this neurotic sort of
pseudo religion that the left is pushing
right now so you can go head over check
that out on
youtube my favorite comment on friday
from jake who says
so if i tell them that i don't have any
documents
you know at the border in the country do
i get fifteen thousand dollars
hello my name is javier where do i sign
up yes new york's
new york is giving fifteen thousand
dollar grands a little over that
actually i think it's fifteen thousand
six hundred dollars
to illegal aliens they're not gonna let
you the american citizen
go out run your business work your job
but they will
pay people five figures to violate
our laws that is how backwards things
have become
please call me miguel miguelito yes
miguelito from that
latin famously latin american country of
sicily
that's a lot i guess they spoke latin
there some time ago that would
uh look if i had an extra fifteen
thousand dollars in the bank that would
help me
certainly sleep easier at night uh the
way i'm already sleeping easy though
bowling branch
if you dream of comfortable sheets at a
price that won't keep you up all night
look no further than bowling branch
bowlin branch makes the softest organic
sheets on the market they get better
with every wash comfort
is not their only standard by the way
they use 100 sustainable raw materials
they're the first fair trade certified
manufacturer of linen
you can feel as good about your bowling
brand sheets as they feel against
your skin these signature hem sheets
from bowling branch are a bestseller for
a reason buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton in a classic sateen
weave for sheets that get softer over
time i had a queen size pair of these
sheets
they're the greatest sheets i ever used
i love them so much it was wonderful it
really made the early days of my
marriage great then we upgraded we got a
king-sized bed
we didn't have those sheets we didn't
and i we
had we said should we get them i don't
know should we yes we have to of course
we do
and and you really have to get them too
they are the best part about going to
sleep
experience the best sheets that you've
ever felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code michael at checkout
bowling branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code michael the
insistence
by these libs in the mainstream media
that we all get this cova vaccine no
matter how young and how healthy we are
is weird and creepy and the fact that
they want to watch us do it
is even creepier and the fact that they
have been wrong about covid from the
beginning
and they have misled people about two
weeks to slow the spread flatten the
curve find a cure now we're going to be
locked down
according to some people for years at
this point the fact that their
predictions have been wrong two million
people dead
donald trump's timetable is never going
to work trump's timetable on the vaccine
was absolutely 100 correct they don't
have any credibility so why on earth
should i
trust them i'm not saying that vaccines
are terrible i'm not saying i'm not even
saying i won't get the covet vaccine at
some point
i'm just saying i feel no rush to do it
and their insistence that i do
is making me less likely to do it they
also have no explanation
for why the states that have reopened
are watching their coronavirus cases go
down and this
those are republican states and the
states that are continuing to lock down
democrat states
or seeing cases skyrocket they're trying
to come up with a
bunch of cockamamie answers but they
just don't have it here's the today show
trying to figure it out
call it a covid conundrum and states
with the strictest measures in the
country like michigan
pennsylvania and much of new england
cases are on the rise
while in the south states like arkansas
and texas that have reopened businesses
and ripped away mass
mandates are seeing their numbers drop
i'm announcing today
that the statewide mass mandate will be
lifted
people and businesses don't need the
state
telling them how to operate so what
might explain the apparent contradiction
one theory differences in testing rates
alabama has experienced one of the
biggest dips in reported infections more
than 50 percent in two weeks
but it's also dead last in the u.s for
covet testing
only 56 tests per hundred thousand
people that's a fraction
of what you'll find in places like
vermont massachusetts and new york where
numbers are surging
how much does lack of adequate testing
have to do with the numbers that we're
seeing right now
when you don't test your blind and when
you're not testing your you have a false
sense of what the real problem is in
your community
another theory coveted fatigue that's
the theory this goes on for several
minutes and they just go through a bunch
of different theories
as to why their main theory doesn't work
it shows you how desperate they are
absolutely pathetic i think people
should watch the whole clip
at some point go on the internet later
watch the whole nbc clip they're just
throwing spaghetti at the wall but but
even to their point here their their
their best theory that they led with is
well the the reason that it looks like
the states that reopened are fine and
the the democrat states that are still
locked down are are
surging the reason is because the
democrat states are testing more
okay well we're not seeing spikes in
death right we're not seeing spikes
in people's lives falling apart it just
looks like texas and florida and all the
normal
conservative states are fine i mean i
was in texas a few
or rather in florida a few days ago i've
been to florida
several times this year at least three
four times this year and it's great it's
totally fine it's totally normal
but they're not testing they don't know
how bad it is i mean this is the same
sort of logic illogic that you hear from
leftists when they say that oppressed
groups of people just don't understand
how oppressed they are you know that
they're
they're laboring under a false
consciousness when
some allegedly marginalized group goes
about its day
without without thinking about how
terrible their their lives are
no maybe you're just a bunch of
neurotics on the left
and you're you're worrying in an
inordinate way
about this virus which
requires some prudential judgment but
doesn't doesn't imply that you should
completely shut your lives down
absolute neurotic hysteria that has now
been exposed
that they are now scrambling to try to
defend but there is no way to defend it
it is just a weird quirk of the
left-wing psychology so people like
governor desantis in in florida have
been right
the whole time and democrats like well
andrew cuomo for sure
but other leading democrat governors on
coronavirus 2
have been wrong the whole time and
that's just the way it is so desantis
just held
a panel in florida it was with a number
of experts
on the on the virus including harvard
professor dr martin kaldorf
oxford university epidemiologist dr
sunitra gupta
stanford physician and epidemiologist
jay bhattacharya
and stanford professor dr scott atlas he
moderated this discussion
regarding the the response to the covid
pandemic
and the insanity that the left has
foisted on us and you know what happened
they posted this on youtube
and youtube pulled it down youtube said
we can't have this kind of
misinformation this violation of our
community guidelines on
the air so you can have andrew cuomo go
on and spout a bunch of nonsense and
lies about coronavirus totally fine you
can have that on youtube
you can have a bunch of other doctors
frankly with less impressive credentials
than these guys from harvard stanford
oxford
you can have them go on and say that we
all need to hunker down
and maybe come out of our homes in 2027
but if you get a successful governor
and correct experts to go on and
criticize
the liberal establishment's insane
response to coronavirus
that's not allowed and it doesn't matter
governor desantis was elected by the
people too bad
who cares youtube's not gonna not gonna
have it
because youtube has much more political
power than ron desantis
youtube has much more political power
than any republican politician in the
country
in the words of mitch mcconnell big
technology would appear
along with woke america corporate
america generally
this big business would appear to be
running a parallel government
and we need to stop that for
several decades republicans embraced
this really shallow ideology
that suggested that big business good
big government bad anything and frankly
anything government does
bad anything these giant corporations do
totally good including censoring the
people's duly elected representatives
when they tell the truth about
coronavirus
and even beyond well this is true and
this is false and here's a fact and this
is a lie
they're just expressing their political
opinion
about what measures were taken
which obviously there were a ton of
mistakes made along the way i don't
think anybody would deny that
but that's not permissible because that
contradicts the state established
religion
of secular progressivism and so they are
going to be shut down and i think
republicans need to wake up we are
starting to wake up
finally and say oh big business when
they behave in this way and undermine
our whole country and
subvert our constitutional order they're
no better than big government in many
ways they're much worse because there's
not even a semblance of accountability
for these people youtube will just pull
it and ron desantis can complain about
it
he can try to pass some laws in florida
probably even that won't be very
successful who is really running the
country
times like these with such political
craziness makes you want to invest in
physical gold physical gold is not
not the cheapest thing in the world you
know you're not going to reach in your
couch cushions and be able to just buy
several bars of physical gold
but acre has figured out this great way
to let you invest in gold without coming
out of pocket all at once
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30 dollars a month you pay
each month and once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house just recently they introduced
a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash
every month and ships once you reach the
price threshold with acre
taking physical delivery of your gold
means it's safe and sound and
in your hands acre designs their gold in
california
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
they provide industry-first packaging
that looks and feels more expensive
than other gold alternatives also now
they're they're making
a 24-karat gold nine millimeter bullet
for you to buy
i wouldn't actually shoot this thing
that would be a very expensive round uh
but pretty pretty amazing especially
during our ammo shortage
go to getacregold.com michael start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to this url because acre is
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post while you
should be the recipient
mention at get underscore acre that is
getting your gold.com
michael and thank you aker gold for
supporting the show beyond the
coronavirus there is another
major public health threat that our
country faces
you probably haven't heard of this one
hard to take a look at it under a
microscope but
rest assured the cdc director dr
rochelle
walensky uh is focused on it
this would be the serious public health
threat of
racism she says quote
the disparities seen over the past year
were not a result of covet 19 instead
the pandemic illuminated inequities that
have existed for generations
and revealed for all of america unknown
but often unaddressed
epidemic impacting public health
racism what we know is this
racism is a serious public health threat
that directly affects the well-being of
millions of americans
as a result it affects the health of our
entire nation
not one sentence in that statement
was coherent not one idea that was
expressed
by the cdc director made any sense
racism is not a public health threat
it's not a serious public health threat
it's just not a public health threat at
all
not every bad thing is a public health
threat but there is a reason that
they're trying to frame it this way
this is this this is the heart of my
talk that i coincidentally that i or
providentially perhaps
that i just gave at ave maria college
everything needs to be made
scientific saying that very narrow
empirical modern idea of science
everything now needs to
fit into that racial hatred is bad
it is not a public health threat but
because the the only way that we can
discuss
anything anymore is in this very shallow
narrow language of
physical material science everything's
got to be gussied up
in that sort of language why why is
racism bad
you ever i know we're all told racism is
really really bad you know so what is
racism right
hatred antagonism towards someone on the
basis of their race
uh bad stuff why is it bad
can you i can i can answer why it's bad
because it's an offense against human
dignity
because man is made in the image of god
that's why that's it it's not
complicated that's it very simple
was that one sentence good okay now if
you
don't believe in god and you
sort of deny or at least ignore all the
metaphysical aspects of our life you
know our hopes our joys our loves
dignity all that sort of stuff and you
just believe in the physical stuff
why is racism bad you can't give an
answer there is no answer
you can't really say anything's bad or
anything's good for that matter
so these people these people who have
absolutely no
political philosophical theological
education or sophistication whatsoever
and frankly they don't have much
scientific education
either they try to gussy everything up
in the
the normal language that we hear about
public public
health
manifestly that is manifestly racism is
not a public health threat
and even if it were it wouldn't be a
threat to the people who aren't of the
affected races
right you can't you can't explain why
racism is bad
with that really narrow silly
vocabulary you have to expand your mind
a little bit but we can't because
the minute that you start granting the
existence of a metaphysical reality
of an objective moral order of the
supernatural there's a natural world and
then there's the supernatural world
the moment that you admit of that then
the state religion of secular
progressivism falls apart
and the state religion of secular
progressivism by the way now hinging on
this neurotic
fear of death that has perfectly healthy
millennials putting 17 masks on their
face and getting shots on television
to to show their supreme virtue
that is embarrassing stuff you should
not
you should not make that your religion
speaking of
racial hatred and public and actual
public health threats
you're going to be shocked to hear this
if you're driving pull over if you're
standing up
sit down there's a new report out
that shows that cities that held
black lives matter protests
uh saw their murder rate shot up
uh shoot up rather in the last few years
and that's shocking
with because i've been told by
places like cnn that the blm protests
are mostly peaceful
so it's so weird how those cities where
blm takes over
see their murder rates skyrocket between
2014 and 2019 so not just 2020 but
actually excluding 2020 from 2014 to
2019 because you know blm's been around
for a while
these places saw a 10 increase in
murders this was uh preliminary stuff
from a study conducted by travis
campbell who's a phd student at umass
amherst
uh said that these cities with protests
read riots uh had quote somewhere
between
1 000 and 6 000 more homicides than
would have been expected if places
with protests were on the same trend as
places that did not have protests
imagine what that number is going to
look like when you add 20 20 into it
where you had the most explicit street
violence
that we've seen political street
violence that we've seen in our country
in a very long time
and this is by the way this is not just
being reported by the daily wire
or a conservative outlet this is being
reported by vox vox.com which is a
left-wing outlet if we want to address
the public health threats of
racial hatred and tension maybe we
should shut down blm
maybe the federal government should go
in and shut down that organization like
they would shoot down the mob or the
clan
i wish bill barr had done this when he
was attorney general
during the madness of 2020 i understand
he was in a difficult position
it's very tricky when you've got the
entire liberal establishment
the woke corporations funneling tens of
millions of dollars into this
organization
which was effectively the militant wing
of the democratic party
i get it i get that it was really tough
but blm
was a terrorist organizat is a terrorist
organization
that targets civilians with violence to
achieve political ends
that should not be permitted to operate
in the united states if there were
anything even remotely like that on the
right
the people who ran it would be in prison
the fbi would be
shutting that thing down but because
it's left wing because the
establishment the public sector and the
private sector all working
they all kind of look like the same
sector because they're so
powerful and so rich they're not being
shut down
and they're really rich they are really
really rich there is a great headline
from the new york post today after news
came out
that the co-founder of blm patrice
cullors
has been spending millions and millions
of dollars on houses
buying up beautiful homes the headline
in the new york post is
black lives matters or
the other one is buy large mansions
that's the
other new meaning of blm patrice colors
is a leftist activist that is her career
that's what she's done
she did not start some business other
than blm i guess that is
a pretty pretty effective corporation in
america
she did not invent some cool gizmo she
didn't work in finance for a long time
she's made all of her money on race
hustling
and radical marxist activism
her words not mine she's admitted this
on on air
she's a trained marxist she
then readdressed this when that old
video came to light and she said yeah i
like i like marxist activism yeah that's
what we're doing
this is the topic by the way of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
thank you to everybody who has
pre-ordered it we have some great stuff
we're gonna be doing the audiobook soon
you can order a first edition
autographed copy of that at premiere
collectibles
the the topic of that book is how we
went from
some obscure brilliant actually
left-wing theorists
about a hundred years ago up to blm
today what that through line is what
political correctness is what woke-ism
is what cancel culture is
so patrice cullers might be facing a
little bit of a cancel culture on her
own because now it's come to light
she just she just snagged four high-end
homes
for 3.2 million bucks in the u.s alone
who knows what the other what other
purchases she's made
now you're going to hear that patrice
culler she made her own money in some
places
she made a little bit of money selling a
blm book
okay that was her kind of her own money
where did the rest of this money come
from i don't really know
now you're going to hear people say this
is not fair and this is awful and maybe
patrice colors is gonna
gonna be booted from blm yeah maybe
maybe not something tells me though that
she just wields political power
in a very clever way and she'll be fine
it's not a big shock oh my gosh you know
wow
she made a lot of money of course she
did big politics makes big money that's
the way it goes big money invites big
politics
and you're going to hear some
conservatives say oh well now this now
this communist is
is perfectly fine with capitalism now
that she's rich
yeah it was always sort of the same
thing there's always a power grab what
the left is doing is not coherent
ideologically or otherwise and so yeah
it's a big power grab but guess what
they grab the power
they have the power this broad left-wing
movement from the
radical explicit communists like
patrice cullors all the way to
the more mainstream types in the elected
office who support them
they now have the power of the parallel
government of the liberal establishment
they have more power than ron desantis
in florida they have more power than
elected republicans
maybe we should start amassing and
wielding political power
for the good not for the not for the bad
like they do for the good
ourselves one way to do that you got to
get educated one great way to get
educated
great courses with the great courses
plus you get unlimited streaming access
to thousands of video lectures on
virtually anything that interests you
you can learn chess from an expert you
can explore the cosmos
you can even get tips on how to train
your dog the possibilities are endless
and with the great courses plus
the content is all thoroughly vetted
fact-based information that you can
trust from some of the best professors
and top experts in their field
all over the world plus you can download
the great courses plus app
and watch or listen on any device
anytime you want so you start on one
device you can switch to another device
i really like this i realized a few
years ago that i was extremely
uneducated
and i would need to dedicate some
portion of my life
to educating myself it's just the way
our system works these days
the great courses plus is a terrific way
to do it
head on over if you want to experience
that aha moment for yourself with the
great courses plus
right now my listeners will get a free
month of unlimited access
show your support of the show sign up
through the special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles do not miss out on this you get
a free trial now
at the great thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles
you can check out the resistance today
uh on ben shapiro show because he's he's
making a similar point to the one i'm
making he's taking it from a little bit
of a different angle
that the the resistance is actually
basically the most powerful force
in america also episode five
for the candace show we can't get enough
of candace owens if you haven't checked
it out yet
what are you waiting for this fearless
thought leader hosts a lively series of
guests each week
for a panel discussion interviews
and her signature cancel corner this
week she'll be hosting comedian and
podcaster adam corolla
tune in because you do not want to miss
this conversation the show streams on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
dailywire.com you can get the audio
podcast canvas on apple spotify
or wherever you listen to your podcasts
if you need some candice owens in your
feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify and subscribe today
be sure to leave a 5 star review
if you like what you hear head on over
to dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
welcome back to the show
speaking of radicals throwing around big
sums of money you've got blm
buying up beautiful mansions in
california wow that's great big politics
big money
and you've got joe biden throwing money
in the other direction
the biden administration tacitly
admitting that there is a crisis on the
southern border
we've got record number of of foreign
nationals pouring over here record
number of
unaccompanied minors i i was going to
say children but a lot of them are like
16 17 year old gangsters so some are
children
some are they're minors sort of but
you know it's a little bit dicey joe
biden's
big strategy to deal with this problem
he's going to give them a lot of money
not just the foreign nationals places
like new york are cutting checks 15 000
checks to to the illegal aliens
themselves but what joe biden wants to
do to try to stem this tide of illegal
immigration
is he wants to send a bunch of money to
guatemala honduras
and el salvador this according to
roberta jacobson
who is the white house's southern border
coordinator she told this to reuters she
didn't say exactly who would get the
cash she didn't say exactly how much
money
but that's the plan do you see
how backwards this is
two totally separate visions for dealing
with this problem and for america
you had donald trump who's whose
program was we're going to cut off your
money
if you don't stop sending people right
it was about threats
it was about reworking trade deals it
was we're going to build the wall in
mexico is going to pay for it
and then is mexico going to write a
check no not exactly but they are going
to negotiate things
on trade on tariffs right so you've got
the threat you've got build the wall
you've got do not come here you've got
we're going to make it really hard if
you do come here we're going to send you
right back
get tough is the trump administration
plan and you've got joe biden who says
come to the border
surge come into our country and then
it's politically disadvantageous to him
so he says
okay well i still yeah come come but
maybe not yet come in a week or two and
we're going to send
more taxpayer money we're already
straining our resources but we're going
to send more money to these countries
please
maybe keep your people here what
what do you think is going to happen
so when trump did it the numbers went
down good
when biden is doing it the numbers will
not go down the numbers will not go down
one because the base of the democratic
party doesn't want them to
but two no one has an incentive for them
to go down
the foreign nationals are going to pour
over the border because
they're they've been told to by joe
biden for one
and two they know that there's going to
be a mass amnesty if democrats can
can grab enough influence so they want
to get here before the amnesty comes
through
but what about these countries guatemala
el salvador honduras
do you think that this government which
is now going to be
making a ton of money because of the
crisis
from the united states do you think that
they're going to try to
minimize the crisis no
they're going to get a lot of money i
mean it's and it's bad for the country
because they're losing a lot of people
who could be talented you know young
ambitious people are now leaving those
countries and going to the united states
but it doesn't really matter that much
because a lot of these
governments honduras el salvador
guatemala
are not particularly strong and the
cartels have a lot of political power
there there's a ton of corruption
so the money is going to dissipate and
then the crisis is going to persist and
then we're going to
spend more money doesn't
doesn't make sense and what are we doing
it for because we're told
this is how you remedy racism that's
kind of what it all comes down to isn't
it
racism racism this and racism that
i think most pro-immigration arguments
center around that never mind that we
take more people
by a lot by a country mile than anywhere
else in the world
never mind that immigration into the
united states over the last 60 years
is the largest movement of people ever
in the history of the world ever
recorded
still we can never do enough to make up
for our awful racism
pete buddha judge just made this point
pete buddha judge former mayor of
southbound his father actually one of
the most prominent radical theorists
in the academy he was the founder
and a former president of the
international ramsey society
referring to antonio gramsci this
brilliant
marxist philosopher and communist
politician one of the people really
credited with creating political
correctness
who might detail in my book buddha judge
is now the transportation secretary
and buddha judge says you know we need
to
really rethink the way we do roads i'm
not just here to fill potholes baby
racism is built into our roads and we
gotta fix it
we're going to create billions and
billions of dollars in economic
opportunity and we have to make sure
that happens equitably so let me talk
about two parts of that
the first is where the investments
happen where are we going to fix the
bridge where are we going to improve the
road where are we going to lay the pipe
and we've got to make sure we're doing
that equitably especially knowing that
it was often in black and brown
communities
that there was either a failure to
invest and you didn't have a good road
or transit system
in a certain neighborhood or the
investment came through in the wrong way
like a highway dividing a black
neighborhood in two there's been a lot
of that
in the america and the interstate system
the interstate system was built to keep
certain groups in and certain groups out
so it was built on a racist system
correct
yeah often this wasn't just a an act of
neglect often
this was a conscious choice there is
racism physically built into some of our
highways
those damn roads i hate those racist
white supremacist
roads got to cancel those roads we got
to kick those roads off twitter you know
we got us those ah man it's it's it's
one thing
for according to democrats half the
country to be
nazis and white supremacists racists you
know
but the roads too we gotta lose all
right gotta read gotta remake the whole
country then
what is buddha judge saying why is he
saying it
he's saying that the highway system
he's obviously exaggerating
immensely but i want to get i want to
give a good argument for for the point
he's trying to make
he's saying that america is totally
racist
right the whole the whole country is
racist it's been racist forever until
like right now when we're still racist
but we're in a crisis and the future is
not going to be racist but racism racism
racism
and so we got to fix that and you know
the roads being a part of america are
part of this american racism and they
were used they were built by racists
for racists and everything is about race
and therefore we need to do something
about it now
i'm gonna grant i'm not gonna grant his
point that the roads are racist or
something
but i am going to grant his broader
observation about human nature
take race out of it race just like
science is the only way that we can now
think about the world
race is the only way that we can think
about sin so
if you if you use the correct language
here it starts to make more sense he's
saying look
human nature is broken people are sinful
and the people who built the roads are
sinful and
there was sinfulness built into this
and therefore it's not perfect and
therefore there's some injustice
involved
and that's why we need to correct that
injustice
okay that's a that's a sort of
unobjectionable point
right of course all human endeavors are
involved some sin because our free will
has been compromised by sin because
adam had to eat that damn apple right
really evade it first but it's adam you
know okay i don't want to get into the
gender politics of it okay we're
sticking with race for now
the problem here is buddha judge seems
to
exclude himself from the sinfulness of
man
from this brokenness the left broadly
when they say everything was racist in
the past but now we're going to redo
everything and make it better
they seem to ex and you know they're
using this term race as a stand-in for
sin
they're excluding themselves they think
they're so perfect
so the reason they're going after the
roads is because the roads
just connect the whole country they're
right at the heart of the country it's
how we move it's how we live
so if you can remake even the roads you
can
remake the whole country it's it's about
how ambitious this revolution is going
to be
and the reason that their revolutionary
radical plans are destined to fail is
because they themselves
are just as sinful as the people that
they castigate
and furthermore because they don't even
recognize that they're talking about sin
they think it's all just about race or
something
because of this secular religion of
progressivism
they can only see skin deep they can
only see the physical stuff they can't
really make sense
of the metaphysical stuff which is
really what it what is the motivation
here
this is the creed that is now being
taught at american
universities that america is racist
and rotten to the core university of
oklahoma now
is mandating not just diversity
and inclusion and equity training
by the way someone pointed out to me
diversity inclusion
and equity uh the letters spelled die
maybe that tells you something about the
country i don't maybe it's just a
coincidence
they are mandating not just this
diversity inclusion and equity
training they're also mandating that
students
agree with their preferred answers so
you do the training you take a test what
do you think about this what's your
opinion about that
it's not just that they require you to
take the test you now have to agree with
their positions and
certain first amendment activists
right putative first amendment activists
you might call them free speech
absolutists which is a group it's a sort
of
i like their impulses but i think
they've really gone wrong and i think
they've actually kind of screwed up the
battle over political correctness
it's the thesis of my book speechless
they're really upset about this they say
schools have no right to mandate a
viewpoint
i think that's ridiculous and i know uh
some really excitable conservatives more
libertarians but some excitable
conservatives
over over recent years have have bought
into this idea but it's just
preposterous of course schools and
universities
can mandate a viewpoint
education is necessarily coercive that's
what you do they're going to mandate the
viewpoint the 2 plus 2 equals 4 right
yeah a good school would mandate the
viewpoint that
america was founded on christian
principles
first in 1620 with the mayflower and
later in 1776
right that's just that's history
schools would mandate that uh
shakespeare wrote a play about the
prince of denmark not the prince of
tibet
right that's that's just what the book
is about and if the book is about one
thing it's not about some other thing
universities education has a mission
it's oriented towards something william
f buckley jr the most mainstream
conservative that
ever there was in the 20th century in
god and man at yale his book about
what's gone wrong at the universities
explicitly rejected the argument that
many conservatives
now are mistakenly making namely that
schools shouldn't
shouldn't have any points of view and
schools shouldn't
coerce any beliefs that we can have
academic freedom he the subtitle of the
book is the superstitions of academic
freedom
he calls academic freedom a hoax and it
is a hoax and i think as
i understand that some conservatives are
making this argument that schools
shouldn't
have any viewpoints or require any
viewpoints because they think that
that's the best way
to protect against the woke insane
leftist viewpoints that the schools are
pushing now
but it's not because the the argument
itself is incoherent
and honest conservatives admitted this
until about five minutes ago
so it's not going to work in the long
run the longer we've made that argument
the more
ground we've lost we have to make the
more difficult argument
the more courageous argument but the
much more coherent one
that yes of course educators are going
to have a point of view and of course
they're going to teach you things
not just how to think but specifically
what to think because the only way to
figure out how to think is to understand
what to think the only way you can start
to think about mathematics is to
understand that 1 plus 1 equals 2
and 2 plus 2 equals 4 and you learn a
bunch of rudimentary things and only
then
can you start thinking about higher
calculus or analysis or whatever
you have to learn that the battle of
hastings happened in 1066
you have to learn that the american
revolution
kicks off in 1775 1776 before you can
start thinking about the broader themes
of history we need to acknowledge that
and say yes obviously educators
can teach us things they just shouldn't
be teaching us this rotten woke nonsense
that is anti-historical that is deeply
un-american
and that makes everyone ignorant that's
the point
i know it requires courage it requires a
spine to make that argument but we got
to do it
sorry speaking of good mandates
i've got to get to this this is a great
a great new
law it's in tennessee my wonderful state
of tennessee all my exes are in texas so
i hang my hat in tennessee
a bill is advancing through the
tennessee state legislature that would
require abortion facilities
to bury or cremate the remains of
aborted fetuses
this is an example of a good government
mandate
you know right now tennessee code
requires that pets and animals
be disposed of by burial or cremation
but little human babies who are killed
in the womb
are not you can just just throw them out
or
i guess planned parenthood can sell
their body parts like they've been
caught on camera doing
so little little puppies get better
treatment than human babies
even if you don't buy into the argument
even if you don't understand rather
that a baby is a baby that human life
exists and grows and matures
and i'm an adult now but i used to be a
toddler and i used to be a baby and i
used to be a fetus
it's all the same thing surely you would
admit that whatever you want to call the
little baby in the womb
he's got to be worth as much as a like a
puppy right or a cat
don't you think and if so don't you
think they should
be entitled to the same sort of dignity
now in the really shallow ossified
conservative movement of the last couple
of decades
we've been told any government mandate
any regulation is bad it makes us less
free
this kind of government mandate makes us
more free
certain government mandates such as
requiring
abortionists to cremate or bury
aborted babies certain mandates like
that make us
more free how so
because it it acknowledges
humanity the a better government mandate
would be
you can't have abortions that would make
us much freer
it would certainly make the babies freer
the babies who are being killed for
abortion
but there are it's a little tricky to
see this
with the topic of abortion so i'll give
you a clearer example
but how certain mandates can make people
more free and how this mistaken
conception of liberty has really
messed up the conservative movement
heroin is a very very addictive drug
people who get hooked on heroin will do
anything they can
to get more heroin
if you make heroin illegal
some people will still use heroin but
fewer people will i know that there is a
kind of fantasy among some
anarchist types or you might say
libertarian types i don't even want to
use that word though i think it's
offensive to real libertarians
that say well if you make heroin legal
then no one will use heroin that's just
not true that's not how it works in
practice it's never how it's worked in
practice
if you make heroin illegal fewer people
will use it
if fewer people are using heroin the
country will be freer
okay according to the modern liberal
ridiculous conception of liberty
being able to shoot up heroin is the
height of freedom
the heroin addict he's the freest man in
the world but we all know that's a lie
we know that the heroin addict is a
slave he's a slave to his
basest desires and appetites and
passions he hasn't cultivated
his will he hasn't cultivated his
intellect
he cannot use his higher faculties they
are dead in atrophied and he is
basically an animal pursuing his lusts
and his appetites
ironically if you make heroin legal and
you say anyone can use heroin if you
want to you are making people less free
now we all can see this i think when it
comes to something like heroin
but this is true of other matters as
well
a good example of this would be one of
the touchstone issues in the culture war
internet pornography from the very
beginning of our country before the
beginning of our country and for
hundreds of years after the beginning of
our country
our statesmen understood that there is
no free speech protection for obscenity
they understood that obscenity is
licentiousness
and licentiousness is not the same thing
as liberty it's actually the opposite of
liberty
so they either outright banned or
heavily regulated obscene materials
you have you have to show an id if you
want to go buy a playboy at the magazine
stand if those even still exist
if either playboy or magazine stands
still exist
with the advent of the internet porn
became ubiquitous during the clinton
administration there was
a direct attempt to try to regulate this
stuff it was totally bipartisan
there was the communications decency act
which is actually where we get the
battle over section 230 in big tech that
comes from a law that was in part
designed
to clean up obscenity on the internet
and there was another law that came out
around this time
called coppa the child online protection
act i detail all of this in my upcoming
book speechless by the way available now
for pre-order
that uh law was held up in the process
and then eventually
over the last 20 years we've we've
gotten so shallow in our thinking in
this country
that we it lost political support and it
didn't really go anywhere
you'll notice that a lot of the
conservatives clamoring to get rid of
porn online porn
are young men the people who write into
my show or i see at events
who are really the hottest on this topic
are zoomers
are teenage boys and guys in their early
twenties
well that's weird don't you shouldn't
those be the guy those guys are probably
the ones most likely to look at porn
right that's the point it's so funny
that in our culture
we always hear that young men need to
talk about their feelings these angry
young white men especially they need to
talk about their feelings well okay now
they are talking about their feelings
they're saying get rid of this porn
because it's screwing up their lives
and what does the culture tell oh you're
a bunch of uh incels you're a bunch of
you're a bunch of losers in your
basement or something
maybe they are maybe that's the problem
maybe they're recognizing that like
heroin there is other sort of material
like
porn that enslaves you to other base
desires and this is really bad and this
does not expand your liberty like some
shallow people on the right have said
you know over the last 20 years
but it actually constricts your liberty
not
not good stuff before we go i have to
mention actually this is a great point
to mention this on this this difference
between liberty and licentiousness this
difference between
duty and entitlement prince philip gotta
pour one out for prince philip
i wish he could have lived another 99
year i'm not going to actually pour out
my leftist ears here but
what what an admirable guy he was
britain's
prince philip the husband to queen
elizabeth
died uh he's not was 99 years old he he
lived a good life
but i think the reason that so many
people are quest fallen that this guy
died
is not because you know gosh he was cut
down in his prime flipping his vet
or something no he had a good run we all
die eventually
despite the neurotic hysteria of people
wearing 17 masks
even though they're 30 years old and
perfectly healthy
prince philip epitomized an age
and an attitude that is gone
he's sort of the anti-meghan markle
they're polar opposites
in the royal family he's the
representative of what has been called
the greatest generation and she is a
representative sadly of millennials i'm
sorry to admit
this was a guy who endured a lot of
hardship he was
born in corfu his family was deposed
they had to
escape under threat of death much of his
family
was killed in russia
he had his mother was a schizophrenic
he endured terrible terrible hardship he
was schooled at a
basically a spartan academy where he had
to take cold showers and run around
barefoot
he comes into britain and as a man
without a state he didn't have a state
he was a stateless person
he comes and becomes an adopted brit he
didn't even have a last name
because he was part of a royal family he
marries queen elizabeth and his entire
life is about
duty and service because that is a good
thing to do and that is what is expected
of people and that is dignified and that
actually speaks to
an exalted freedom he did not indulge
his own appetites
very very few stories if any of prince
philip just
indulging himself in his own base
desires it was
all about service and what ought to be
done
and he did it very admirably
and i think a lot of people fear that
that generation is passing away
elizabeth still demonstrates that
will we be able to demonstrate that
afterward or are we all going to be a
bunch of hysterical little ninnies
running around
fearing death fearing everything fearing
our own shadow crying about what we're
entitled to
crying about all the ways that we've
been slighted or are we going to stand
up
stop indulging that lowest
aspect of our character and walk with a
bit of dignity and true freedom hope we
can i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you